hey youtubers it's Charlie so big news
Marvel finally confirmed the Luke Cage
cast now we'd already heard about Mike
Colter in a couple of the other
characters but now it's official so just
going down the list of comic book
characters we have cotton mouth he'll be
one of the big villains of course his
cousin Mariah Dillard who's actually
being played by alfre woodard which is a
pretty huge deal I'm a big fan of hers
but then we have misty night which is a
really big deal detectives scarf which
is being played by frank whaley which i
think is kind of funny then we have
shades who's also supposed to be one of
the villains although he might be a
version of the striker character now
quite confirmed on that yet in rosario
dawson who's continuing to play claire
temple now technically she's not night
nurse but everyone's thinking of her as
night nurse just to talk about a couple
of the bigger characters you guys might
not know a lot about misty night was
actually a police officer that lost her
arm in the line of duty Tony Stark gave
our Bionic replacement she started a
private detective agency and proceeded
to team up with the Heroes for Hire Luke
Cage iron fists etc she even had a
romance with iron fist for a brief
period not a whole lot is known about
cottonmouths origin but he does have
super strength he's into the drug lord
in New York City initially when Luke
Cage was framed for drug possession and
sent to prison it was cottonmouth drugs
that strikers stolen planted on cage so
they do have some history together we'll
see how the TV show plays with that now
they have released an official synopsis
for the series and it just reads Luke
Cage is a former gang member who is
framed for a crime in prison he
volunteers for medical experiment that
goes awry giving him super-strength and
bulletproof skin using his newfound
powers cage escapes and becomes a hero
for hire his arch enemy is Willie
striker a former childhood friend from
Harlem the two committed petty crimes
together and both fell for the same
woman riva Connors which led to their
eventual falling out it was striker who
framed cage for a drug deal and sent him
to prison and it does sync up with a
comic book arc but just like daredevil
it's going to be based on the comics it
won't be a direct adaptation they'll
just be taking bits and pieces now since
they just finished casting it means
they're getting ready to start shooting
Luke Cage so I would expect it to drop
sometime towards the end of next year
that's usually about how long it takes
to finish him you know maybe maybe
sometime during this summer maybe not
all the way to the end of next year just
remember Jessica Jones is dropping
November 20th so that's like the ass end
of the year I don't know if they'll make
us wait that long for Luke a
I mean we're going to see him in Jessica
Jones it's just that he won't be the
main character he'll probably just be a
small part of it if you want to reach
some awesome Luke Cage stories from the
comics here's just a couple of
suggestions essential Luke Cage Power
Man vol 2 alias vol 4 secret origins of
jessica jones Luke Cage noir and then
essential Luke Cage Power Man vol 1 in
fact that last one vol 1 is probably the
best place to start especially if you
guys have Marvel unlimited all of this
might not be on Marvel unlimited but
most of it will be there I think a lot
of people are wondering with jessica
jones is going to feel like they're just
you know a little bit worried because it
doesn't feel like a traditional
superhero story which i think is what's
going to make it really interesting the
pitch for Luke Cage just sounds like any
other superhero story though giant dude
punches the out of villains pretty
easy sell so if you like gangland
stories in standard superhero fair Luke
Cage is going to be your show and if it
wasn't clear a lot of the story will
take place in and around Harlem it's
just that Hell's Kitchen is where
daredevil takes place jessica jones is
kinda around there Luke Cage is going to
be on the north edge of that up near
harlem i don't know about you guys but I
am super excited to see a nice twist on
the captain america origin story
hopefully they'll have some visual
Easter eggs you know just some mirroring
for how Steve Rogers got his powers with
the Super Soldier Serum if you didn't
know Luke Cage or Power Man however you
want to think about him got his powers
from an offshoot program of the Super
Soldier Serum originally in the comics
when every day beauty was kind of a riff
on blaxploitation so hopefully there'll
be some funny blaxploitation jokes think
about some of the jokes that Quentin
Tarantino has in Jackie Brown like
hopefully we'll see some of that type of
humor I mean make no mistake we're in
the Avengers universe i mean the
avengers tower even shows up in the
background of the jessica jones teaser
so this is Marvel's world but Luke Cage
is based on blaxploitation so whenever
they do new characters they're always
really good about poking fun at their
origins especially if they're somewhat
problematic speak which I know a lot of
you guys are asking about David Tennant
possibly turning purple during jessica
jones i have absolutely no idea i'm not
expecting it just because that might end
up looking a little bit too funny on
screen but we'll see let me know though
which of the Netflix series are you guys
most excited about daredevil season 2
jessica jones season 1 or luke cage
season 1 now obviously i'm not talking
about Iron Fist yet because they haven't
cast an actor they haven't found a
writer
haven't found a director yet either
there's just too many things they
haven't done with that yet I think by
the end of the year though they probably
will announce a director and a writer
they have to do that before they
announced the actor bare minimum though
they'll probably announce who's playing
Iron Fist by the time daredevil season 2
airs and if you weren't sure about when
that is it's going to be around the same
time that daredevil season one aired
like right around captain america civil
war so in related news agents of shield
isn't coming back for two weeks but
Gotham season two starts next Monday and
then heroes reborn starts next week too
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll start doing a little bit
more agents of shield stuff as we get
closer a lot of you guys have requested
that I do some more Luke Cage videos and
some more iron fist videos I'll start
doing a little bit more of that as we
get closer to Jessica Jones that's
actually coming up pretty soon why you
guys wait for all that stuff to drop you
can click here for all my daredevil
season to all my marvel netflix videos
and you can click here for this week's
episode of vixen and all my flash
trailers and all that stuff thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you